yeah former bosses of summers Britain's
biggest supermarkets and retailers have
been warning you mentioned it there in
the interview with mr. Robert leaving
the EU would have a devastating effect
on the economy writing in the mail on
Sunday they say brexit leaving the
European Union would be inevitably lead
to price rises on the high street and
would hit consumers the hardest while
Sir Terry Lee he is one of them he's of
course the former head of Britain's
biggest retailer Tesco and a very good
morning to you
so Terry well I put it to dominic rather
and you know the public you get a bit
sick of this here one dire warning from
one side one dire warning from the next
and they they scratch their heads and
wonder if it really is true well we've
spoken about things that matter to the
consumer the British economy is a
consumer economy 65 percent of it is
made up of household spending so the
consumers matter in this and it's been a
success story in the last 10 or 20 years
there's been an explosion of choice
improvements of quality in the goods and
services people buy and that's happened
within the European Union if we left
that would be put into peril but you
know I mean you know much more than I do
and did you were there when when when
Tesco expanded into some other European
countries and tones in the water
we've all been to two supermarkets in in
other European countries and they're
kind of cirrhotic some of them badly rum
there's this sense that you know Britain
is way ahead when it comes to to retail
in getting prices down for the consumer
what why would that change on leaving
the European Union Britain is why I had
you know London has become the world's
financial center as part of the EU
Britain is a leading innovator in retail
it's a leader now in the digital economy
and he ecommerce within the EU but it
benefits from being a part of that 500
million single market we attract
investment into digital businesses into
retail into the car industry which help
consumers here at home because it up
competition and investment in innovation
but it's because we're part of that
single why would prices go up you know
this is about that the famous shopping
basket
the Margaret that's a shopping basket
why would that cost more if we leave the
European Union you've effectively
talking about tariffs and barriers if
for a number of reasons actually first
of all for tariffs as soon as we leave
we come outside of the single market we
would then go to WTO tariffs so the
costs of clothing and food and cars
would go up but also more importantly we
we in the last 10 or 20 years have
become part of an integrated supply
chain which is based in Europe that
inevitably would face huge disruption
and that would increase prices and there
two further reasons the pound would be
hit hard the shock to the system the
loss of confidence would drive sterling
down and that would put a is that the
main driver behind the argument and we
are seeing and you know there may be
other reasons involved yes the pound has
been slipping down and there is even
even the leave campaign admit this a
period of uncertainty of course there is
but that would correct itself wouldn't
it if Britain left and negotiated and an
orderly retreat from the European Union
I don't think so no this would be a
tremendous shock at a very delicate time
you know the Great Recession of 2007 to
2012 hit families hard they're gradually
recovering their confidence the whole
economy depends on a confident consumer
and that would be hit by the shock to
the system house prices would go down
food prices clothing prices would go up
people would stop investing in the UK
that would cost jobs now all of those
things would hit consumer confidence
that would put okay but it's this issue
of food prices why would they go up
because you know people remember when we
joined the Common Market as then was one
of the big issues was the Common
Agricultural Policy which artificially
inflates prices pays farmers more for
some of the products they produce the
Britain is out of the European Union
that wants to subsidize some of its own
farmers to a similar level it also means
that it isn't then paying into
subsidizing French German Spanish
Italian the list goes on
farmers yeah I'm not a great fan of the
Common Agricultural Policy but but the
cost of that wasn't a good reason to
leave the car
stuff that pales into insignificance
against the cost for all household goods
that would increase when left the
European Union because of increased
tariffs because of a collapse in the
pound because of a loss of investment
here in the UK and you know the you the
EU is our natural trading partner I mean
if you look at economics all over the
world countries trade with the countries
next door if we go looking for trade in
South America and Asia and Africa and so
on goods will cost more they cost more
the further afield that you get them
from
so you know there are three or four very
powerful reasons why if we leave the EU
goods will cost more
have you thought carefully I want to ask
you about you know I mean have your
views being solicited have you taken
call saying so Terry it would be helpful
and given your former role it would be
helpful if you made these points I'm
sure you believe them sincerely but it
would be helpful if you and others got
them out there to try to influence it no
I offered to help because I believe I'm
a great fan obviously of the UK I think
we're a world-class country but it's
important now that we stay in the EU we
depend on the gradual recovery and
consumer confidence is taking place
the irony is many of the things that the
leave was once we can achieve already
you know what matters for people in
Britain is can we build houses can we
improve our hospitals we need better
schools and more skills we need better
infrastructure we can do that now within
the EU and as part of the EU we can then
export what we do well to a market next
to us you know one term leave
campaigners say when you mention all
those things well you know a lot of it
comes back to immigration the free
movement of people's within the European
Union and we need a lot more housing we
need more schools we need more medical
facilities because the population of the
UK is growing very rapidly indeed partly
through immigration and big bosses like
it because it helps them keep wages down
well first of all immigration is a good
thing my parents were immigrants into
the UK and there are many fine examples
of people who've contributed a lot to
the UK
and were originally immigrants it needs
to be better managed but of course you
know there's more immigration from
outside the EU which we can manage then
there is from within the EU and another
thing too we want more British people in
jobs and so the change you know welfare
traps people and and keeps them out of
the labour market if we can get more
British people in they'll be less need
for immigration now this thing about
whether businesses enjoy low wages just
doesn't stand up you know the retail
industry has got a tremendous track
record of paying above the minimum wage
having profit shares and bonuses and
pensions and training programs all above
that we we want our people who work in
the industry to do well last quick
question that so Terry on with your
retailing expertise you know this this
huge issue of BHS I mean I mean do you
think it can continue as a viable
concern or really is that it is that
brand dead in the water
it looks very difficult you know one of
the facts of all this innovation and all
this improvements in retailing is not
everybody can keep up and it looks as if
BHS hasn't done enough to keep up the
locations are good and I'm sure that in
some form they'll find another use well
great see so Terry thank you very much a
TV a time so Terry Lee